one of our favorite sees a Jeremy
Roenick the NBCSN NHL analyst and USA
Hockey Olympians junior Joe Pavelski a
Mike Modano TJ oshi are teaming up with
Niner Sports & Entertainment to engage
to bring you legends on the links this
is a once-in-a-lifetime sweepstakes the
winner being flown out to Lake Tahoe for
a great weekend celebrity golf
championship go to legends on the links
calm to learn more junior how are you
I'm great Dan thanks for plugging our
little excursion this summer what's your
what's your tattoo that you have I fit
my kids so when I retired from from the
NHL I wanted to do something fun with my
kids and they said why don't you tattoo
our names on our yeah so I literally did
it like the day after I retired so it's
one of my favorites so even all the
concussions then you can't help but
listen I don't make great but this one
was a good one yeah but most of my
decisions are a little off for sure
tattoos big in the NHL they are
absolutely well if you'll excuse an
alarm getting you can see nothing but
tattoos I'm Brent burns and he's
obviously anybody have their Stanley Cup
on him oh absolutely like if you win it
if I would have wanted I would have put
it on your back my thigh so everybody
can see it for sure but I Olympians
will put the Olympic rings on their bond
well Ricky Fowler did you know has it on
his forearm yeah a lot of the swimmers
do that as well I would too there's no
question these are things that you do
that are just that the ordinary people
can do and it's a life life memory you
imagine if you know somebody like
Gretzky or Messier but like every time
they won the cup they put all right
we've had some controversy here the
other night
the hand pass yes okay are we and those
officials I guess got suspended for the
rest of the playoffs without which they
should have okay
are we headed towards more replay in the
NHL and do we need more replay in the
NHL well I think it's such a big
business now and everybody is like well
we don't need more replays and stop slow
in the game
down slowing the game down but do you
think that there's 20,000 people or
maybe millions of people in st. Louis
that wouldn't care for five minutes to
go to replay to see if that was actually
hand passed and then you know they still
could be playing it's a big loss for st.
Louis there's no question about it that
they missed the call and listen right
the NHL referees are the best referees
in the world it's a tough tough job
human error is always there but 20,000
people saw it at the same time he's only
four guys missed it I know I'm being a
little bit I think dramatic but well
maybe 20,000 people because all the
people want I'm just saying I'm just
saying in live and in person you know
okay obviously you can see it on the
replay so everybody at home on
television but the people that are there
and you have a Jumbotron that's sitting
right there that's playing replays I
mean just look up at it and just make
the call but to me but they're not
allowed to review that correct which is
what when you have such a big business
and there's so much that rides on teams
winning and moving on and be financially
there's no question that you got to get
the call right okay what do we do to fix
it so for me what would I listen there's
there are extra referees that are at the
game that are sitting in the stands or
sitting in the press box waiting in case
one of the referees or linesman's goes
down so that you have them there and
they're not doing anything but watching
the game like other other spectators why
can't that extra referee be sitting in
the press box with a headset that's
connected to the penalty box and if
there's if there's a discrepancy or
something that's blatantly obvious where
the referee that's sitting up in the in
the press box has the ability to look at
it really quick and can make that call
down if there's a question that the
referees missed I mean you have the
referees there use them well that to me
that's that's the most logical answer
this is what I thought the NFL should do
is just have somebody there who is in
the booth who can help them on the field
just like New Orleans there is just do
it for the playoff games like just start
with the playoff games because those are
the ones that matter the most and if
somebody can help you get the call right
and we have the technology
my biggest problem though j.r is it used
to be called instant replay now it's
called replay because it's not done
correct and that's the bait that's the
big question
right but listen people are they're
having a good time it's not gonna it's
not gonna take 15-20 minutes you're
gonna see it you're gonna see it
relatively quick but it's more important
and I think more people would appreciate
the fact that they got the call right
now you can't do everything you can't
have the referee that's up in the press
box watching call down and say oh you
know that puck you know that that was an
elbow that's got to be a penalty on
major decision-making
like when Joe Pavelski got cross-checked
in Game seven okay that was not a major
penalty and I think Joe Pavelski will
tell you it was an awful play an
unfortunate play that looked really bad
that changed the whole game it was
accidental accidental and there was
another play where Michael Ferlin made a
hit he got thrown out early in the first
round that was not a major penalty so
when you're making a major call that's
going to influence them a big influence
in the game you have to make sure that
you get it right and I think there's I
mean what we do offsides it replay okay
side's replay I think a little bit more
important would be a hand pass in
overtime that decided the hockey game so
I think the NHL has some work to do I
think they've done a lot to try to keep
keep the referees accountable but
they're neat the referees are gonna make
mistakes there's no question human
errors there it's a hard game it's a
fast game I don't envy their job but
they do do a good job and this one they
just happened to miss you played a
physical style I'm curious if are there
any grudges that you carried over after
hockey like if you see somebody could it
be go Darren Hatcher broke my jaw in
four places he did it on purpose so but
if you see him no I'm fine with him it's
listen I respect the fact that people go
out and play the game hard and you know
I hurt Mike Modano the game before I
knew it was coming back I mean that's
the nature of the game competitiveness
you know did you try to hurt Madonna no
no I tried to get the better of Mike
Modano there's no question never tried
to hurt him but I wanted to know that I
was always present because he was Mike
he was my idol you know as we were
growing up together he was the guy that
I tried to emulate and tried to beat all
the time because he was my competitor so
well cuz we looked at Madonna's like the
the great American hope like he was
gonna be I think he was the best
American ever
that's my personal who else would be on
that list Pat LaFontaine Chris Chelios
Brian Leetch that's pretty good yeah
those are to me those are the top guys
Brett Hall even though he's he has
multiple citizenships but those those
are the guys that I look at the top best
players of all time now us players you
grew up a Bruins fan right I did when
did you stop liking the Bruins I still
like the Bruins but even when you were
playing even when I was playing you know
there's always this little spot in your
heart you know my mom and dad are huge
Bruins fans you know they watch was
there any chance you were getting
drafted by Boston no but I actually had
a chance to sign in Boston in 2001 and
opted to go to Philly because I thought
philia has a better chance of winning a
Stanley Cup they offered me more money
that I signed in Philly but I don't know
I think would've been tough for me to
play at home in Boston I didn't think I
wanted to do that but that their
championship runs have been pretty good
and they're there they're looking really
good right now that's pretty pretty
special well it's become the new title
town with all of the different sports
there they make everybody jealous sorry
everybody are you Richmond I am a
Patriots fan love the Patriots love the
Red Sox
that's so much it brought a Celtics fan
but have you met Brady I have not met
Brady no I would love to you though what
would you say would you say it in that
creepy manner possibly possibly I don't
get too nervous meeting too many people
but he is you I mean he is the goat and
he is he is the greatest thing ever I
mean just look at him well what was it
like with Gretzky though a little bit
different because I competed against
Gretzky no so the first time I met him I
was quiet did you want to make sure you
didn't hurt him
you don't hurt ever hurt Gratz there's
always somebody around who's gonna kick
your ass if you do whether Semenko was
good Marty McSorley Dave semanko
and they were gonna there's a line there
was a line of guys that and you would
have to deal with you know cuz back then
you didn't have instigator rules so you
touch Gretz the wrong way you go out the
next shift you're gonna fight somebody
every single shift it's gonna be it's
gonna be wicked so Gretzky said this a
few years ago to me where he said if I
played today I'd have a hard time
getting 50 goals uh possibly 'men see
how hard it is to score 50 goals I mean
Ovechkin is the only one that's done it
consistently this year we had to last
year we had one I mean you're seeing I
mean I'm
one year I think we had 10 or 12 or 15
guys get 50 yeah i'm Teemu Selanne and
guys you know getting 73 the biggest
difference the biggest difference is the
goaltender's are actually athletic now
before they were just they're just beer
bodies that just you know didn't want to
go on the ice right they would hit with
their sticks it's like the guy you say
well your catcher yeah you know yeah
yeah you play catcher ever
they look like fitzy fritzy yeah dude
you'll see did you have my buddy over
there hey by the way you're rocking the
good jersey I love it Thanks but because
you were coming in I want you to wear
something each other with your beauty I
love it by the way I could fit in that
Jersey to know if if you solve fritzy as
a goaltender yeah in your prime yeah for
sure
just like he's just got that he just got
the build for it yeah he just light him
up yeah little loosey-goosey but then he
can throw a my don't worry buddy but did
you did you ever feel sorry for a
goaltender never no no
they're the ones I picked that position
it's a dumbass position in the world
right let's put on a bunch of games you
ever play it I played it one time when I
was 7 years old and I said isn't no more
it was the worst experience I've ever
had this is just too boring for me to
but to stand in front of a puck with all
that that goes 100 and I got hit in the
jog with 125 miles an hour slap shot
didn't feel good so I wouldn't want to
do that every single day I don't care
how much batting and you have the
titanium yeah on just your left side no
it's just it runs around all the whole
thing that runs right around my chin
area which is why I have such a you know
predominant chin it's not normal but
somebody can hit you in the jaw and you
don't feel it's happened a lot yeah well
my whole thing you know invite people to
hit you in the John I used to you know
almost 50 it's probably not a good idea
to continue taking head shots like that
you know I know McLovin got me got me
Seton got me yeah like there were a
couple of guys that I'm gonna guess it
you don't want to have him hit you in
the jaw oh there's a lot of people that
I would not want to hit me in a John I
had this one this one story written I
mean at playing at the Bob Hope classic
and this is one of those stupid more
stupid things that I did that I've ever
done it was the most rain that they've
ever had at the Bob Hope Classic it was
during the 2004 lockout so we didn't
play they literally cancel day after day
so we had nothing to do
but sit in the bar and and drink beer
well I happen to come across a guy who
was there who was a boxer and we had
this I we had this idea of finding out
who you know can take a punch the best
so for like 30 40 minutes we just stood
there exchanging punches but not when we
not when we were expecting it so I'd be
sitting there drinking off something you
know next time he's gonna my next day
next day my jaw was swollen like this
Dan it was out and it was and it was not
very smart but we both survived it did
you ever think about boxing no I no I
for workouts but again it's like being a
goaltender I just don't I just don't
feel you know having a career choice of
having people punch me in the head and
target my head all the time every once
in a while is okay who wins who wins the
Stanley Cup you know I think there's
something this there's just there's
something in the atmosphere that's
happening around San Jose I mean a lot
of people are mad because everybody says
all they're getting the great calls
they're getting to luck and you know
they're being biased towards San Jose
but Joe Thornton who was a very very
very close friend of mine and probably
the one guy that I've ever played with
Dan and has the most loved by his
teammates by his fans by his team I've
never seen a guy a team work hard to get
somebody a championship I think he will
be with nobody in sales a once Joe to be
the best player ever without a cup and
wouldn't he be he's gonna be definitely
in the top five if that happens but well
who's in that you're in that top five I
don't know if I'm in that top five Mike
Gardner's in that top five you know he
never won a Stanley Cup that's that's a
that's a tough one he's 700 something
goals but I don't know they're just sit
there seems to be a something in the
stars in the atmosphere that that's
happening with San Jose the way that
they're winning and the way that they're
playing I'm gonna go with San Jose now
so explain what you guys are doing at
Tahoe we love that Golf Course it's
great I mean it's one of the best it's
my favorite weekend of the year without
question we're doing the legends on the
Lynx and what we're doing is we're going
out and we're we're having the
sweepstakes we're gonna pick two people
to come out to Lake Tahoe in July and
you're gonna be able to spend time
with myself Joe Pavelski Mike Modano and
TJ oshi people can punch you if they
want if they want for sure we will be
punched and punchy by the end of the
weekend for sure but what will happen is
the the winners will be able to caddy
for us during the pro-am which is great
because you go on the practice range and
you mean you know Charles Barkley Tony
Romo Aaron Rodgers a slew of people that
celebrities that are out there take
pictures with them get to mingle with
them go out to dinner with us one night
as a big fun happy group and yeah Oh
trust me that will be very interesting
the next day how we're gonna feel the
next day but um it's a
once-in-a-lifetime there's no question
it's a when you say legends on the links
this is this is definitely
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity who would
be your one seed all bar all bar yeah I
played with a guy and I know he's gonna
he's gonna kill me for Tess for saying
this but Robert Ashe was my goaltending
Muslim my goaltender in Philly and I've
never seen a guy be able to put more
more Coors lights down than him I think
one time he put like 45 down in a golf
tournament he's one of the greatest guys
in the world Ashley I'm sorry I'm
telling the story but I also heard that
Craig Craig Ludwig would bring a cooler
to the softball games in the summertime
and everybody's like yeah LEDs he
brought all the beer and goes don't
touch it that's mine the whole cooler
hum that go boy did you guys drink
before games I only drank before game
one time it was 94 before we were gonna
lockout in 94 like the players were
gonna stop playing before the playoff
that was gonna be our way of having that
you know the upper hand right so we're
playing in Detroit and we're waiting for
12 o'clock to roll around because at 12
o'clock it was a last game in the season
they were gonna shut the season down so
bunch of us go across the border into
Windsor and we're at the bar we're
boozing we're waiting for 12 o'clock we
went there at 10 o'clock we went there
we were spend the whole day 12 o'clock
didn't come around no call 3 o'clock
came no call finally one of the
teammates get to
call from the National Hockey League now
word 2530 deep for hours deep next thing
you know any child call and say oh we're
gonna strike tomorrow you gotta play
tonight
straight we run straight to reason we
went straight into the into a Joe Louis
Arena we walk in Mike Keenan sees us and
we were just like we're just dripped to
the drip to the bone right and he's just
shakes his head how did you do we tied
3-3 I had a goal in assists so play on
guilt sometimes is the best way the
website to learn more about this is
legends on the links commies Jeremy
Roenick jr. great to see you again buddy
first off by the way I think that Dan
that should come out to my hockey school
this summer in Chicago get you guys get
you guys on the ice not get some
old-time hockey Eddie shore yeah no
that's it July 19 through 20 of 22nd
through 25th come on boys
we'll take a break we're back after this
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]